The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Hi, everyone.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
PROFESSOR: We're getting
towards the end of the semester.
Things are starting to
cohere and come together.
We have one more midterm exam.
So there is an exam
next Thursday, the 18th.
OK?
There will be a problem set due.
It'll be posted later today,
and it will be due next week
on Tuesday as usual.
Of course, next week on Tuesday
is a holiday technically,
so we'll actually make the
due date be on Wednesday.
So on Wednesday at 10 o'clock.
You should think
of this problem set
as part of the
review for the exam.
Material that is covered
today and on Thursday
will be fair game for the exam.
So the format of
the exam is going
to be much more canonical.
It's going to be a
series of short answer
plus a series of computations.
They'll be, roughly speaking,
at the level of the problem
sets, and a practice
exam will be
posted in the next
couple of days.
The practice exam is going
to be of the same general
intellectual
difficulty, but it's
going to be considerably
longer than the actual exam.
So as a check for yourself
here's what I would recommend.
I would recommend sitting
down and giving yourself
an hour and a half or two
hours with the practice exam
and see how that goes.
OK?
Try to give yourself
the time constraint.
And here's one of the
things that-- there's
a very strong correlation
between having
nailed the problem sets, and
worked through all the practice
exams, and just done
a lot of problems,
and doing well on exams.
You'll be more confident.
The only way to study
for these things is just
do a lot of problems.
So on Stellar, for example,
are a bunch of previous problem
sets, and previous
exams and practice
exams from previous years.
I would encourage you to
look at those also on OCW
and use those as practice.
OK, any practical
questions before we
get on to the physics.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Will the exam
cover all the material,
or all the material [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: This is
a cumulative topic.
So the question is does it
cover everything, or just
last couple of weeks.
And it's a cumulative topic,
so the entire semester
is necessary in order
to answer the problems.
Other questions?
OK.
Anything else?
So quick couple of
review questions
before we launch into the
main material of today.
These are going to
turn out to be useful
reminders later on
in today's lecture.
So first, suppose
I tell you I have
a system with energy operator
E, which has an operator A such
that the commutator of E with
A would say plus h bar A. OK?
What does that tell you about
the spectrum of the energy
operator?
AUDIENCE: It's a ladder.
PROFESSOR: It's a
ladder, exactly.
So this tells you that the
spectrum of E, or the energy
eigenvalues En,
are evenly spaced--
and we need a dimensional
constant here,
omega-- evenly spaced
by h bar omega.
And more precisely, that
given a state phi E,
we can act on it
with the operator A
to give us a new state, which
is also an energy eigenstate,
with energy E plus h bar omega.
right?
So any time you see that
commutation relation,
you know this fact to be true.
Second statement.
Suppose I have an
operator B which
commutes with the
energy operator.
OK?
So that the commutator vanishes.
What does that tell
you about the system?
AUDIENCE: Simultaneous
eigenfunctions [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Excellent.
So one one consequence
is that there
exists simultaneous
eigenfunctions phi sub E, B,
which are simultaneous
eigenfunctions of both E and B.
What else does it tell you?
Well, notice the following.
Notice that if we took this
computation relation and set
omega to 0, we get this
commutation relation.
So this commutation relation is
of the form of this commutation
relation with omega equals 0.
So what does that tell
you about the states?
About the energy eigenvalues?
What happens if I
take a state phi sub E
and I act on it with B?
What do I get?
What can you say
about this function?
Well, what is its
eigenvalue under E?
It's E. It's the same
thing, because they commute.
You can pull the E
through, multiply it,
you get the constant E,
you pull it back out.
This is still an
eigenfunction of phi
of the energy operator
with the same eigenvalue.
But is it necessarily
the same eigenfunction?
No, because B may act
on phi and just give you
a different state.
So this is some eigenfunction
with the same energy,
but it may be a
different eigenfunction.
OK?
So let's think of
an example of this.
An example of this is
consider a free particle.
In the case of a
free particle, we
have E is equal to
P squared upon 2m.
And as a consequence
E and P commute.
Everyone agree with that?
Everyone happy with
that statement?
They commute.
So plus 0 if you will.
And here what I wanted to say
is when you have an operator
that commutes with
the energy, then
there can be multiple states
with the same energy which
are different states, right?
Different states entirely.
So for example,
in this case, what
are the energy eigenfunctions?
Well, e to the ikx.
And this has energy h bar
squared k squared upon 2m.
But there's another state, which
is a different state, which
has the same energy.
e to the minus ikx.
OK?
So when you have an operator
that commutes with the energy
operator, you can have
simultaneous eigenfunctions.
And you can also have
multiple eigenfunctions
that have the same
energy eigenvalue,
but are different functions.
For example, this.
Everyone cool with that?
Now, just to make clear
that it's actually
the commuting that
matters, imagine
we took not the free particle,
but the harmonic oscillator.
E is p squared upon 2m plus m
omega squared upon 2 x squared.
Is it true that E-- I'll call
this harmonic oscillator--
does E harmonic
oscillator commute with P?
No, you're going to
get a term that's
m omega squared x
from the commutator.
The potential is not
translationally invariant.
It does not commute
with momentum.
So this is not equal to 0.
So that suggests that this
degeneracy, two states having
the same energy,
should not be present.
And indeed, are the
states degenerate
for the harmonic oscillator.
No.
No degeneracy.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: We did
something [INAUDIBLE]
where I think it said that the
eigenfunctions were complete.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: What does that mean?
PROFESSOR: What does it
mean for the eigenfunctions
to be complete?
What that means is
that they form a basis.
AUDIENCE: So the basis
doesn't necessarily
mean not [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, no one told you
the basis had to be degenerate,
and in particular,
that's a excellent--
so the question here
is, wait a minute,
I thought a basis had to be
a complete set-- if you had
an energy operator and you
constructed the energy eigen--
this is a very good question.
Thank you.
If I have the energy operator
and I construct it's energy
eigenfunctions, then those
energy eigenfunctions
form a complete basis for
any arbitrary function.
Any function can be
expanded in it, right?
So for example, for
the free particle,
the energy eigenfunctions
are e to the ikx,
the momentum eigenfunctions
for any value of k.
But wait, how can there
be multiple states
with the same energy?
Isn't that double
counting or something?
And the important thing is
those guys have the same energy,
but they have different momenta.
They're different states.
One has momentum h bar k.
One has momentum minus h bar k.
And you know that
that has to be true,
because the Fourier
theorem tells you,
in order to form a complete
basis, you need all of them,
all possible values of k.
So there's no problem with
being a complete basis
and having states have the
same energy eigenvalue, OK?
It's a good question.
Other questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So if we have a
potential that only admits
bound states, we'll never
have this commutation
happen basically?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
Excellent.
So the observation is this.
Look, imagine I have a
potential that's not trivial.
It's not 0, OK?
Will the momentum commute
with the energy operator.
No, because it's got
a potential that's
going to be acted upon by P, so
you'll get a derivative term.
But more precisely, if I have
a system with bound states,
I have to have a
potential, right?
And then I can't have P
commuting with the energy
operator, which means I
can't have degeneracies.
So indeed, if you
have bound states,
you cannot have degeneracies.
That's exactly right.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: But doesn't this
break down in higher dimensions?
PROFESSOR: Excellent,
so we're going
to come back to higher
dimensions later.
So the question
predicts what's going
to happen in the
rest of the lecture.
What we're going to
do in just a minute
is we're going to
start working in three
dimensions for the first time.
We're going to leave 1D behind.
We're going to take our
tripped out tricycle
and replace it with a Yamaha.
As you'll see, it has the
same basic physics driving
its, well, self.
It's the same dynamics.
But I want to emphasize
a couple things that
are going to show up.
So the question is,
isn't this story
different in three dimensions?
And we shall see exactly what
happens in higher dimensions.
We'll work in two dimensions.
We'll work in three dimensions.
We'll work in more.
Doesn't really matter how
many dimensions we work in.
You'll see it.
OK, third thing.
You studied this in some
detail in your problem set.
Suppose I have an
energy operator
that commutes with a
unitary operator, U, OK?
So it commutes to 0.
And U is unitary, so U dagger
U is one, is the identity.
So what does this tell you?
Well, first off
from these guys it
tells us that we can have
simultaneous eigenfunctions.
It also tells us too that
if we take our state phi
and we act on it with
U, this could give us
a new state, phi tilde sub
E, which will necessarily
have the same energy eigenvalue,
because U and E commute.
But it may be a different state.
We'll come to this
in more detail later.
But the third thing, and
I want to emphasize this,
is this tells us, look, we
have a unitary operator.
We can always write the
unitary operator as e
to the i of a
Hermitian operator.
So what is the meaning of
the Hermitian operator?
What is this guy?
So in your problem
set, you looked
at what unitary operators are.
And in the problem set, it's
discussed in some detail
that there's a
relationship between
a unitary transformation,
or unitary operator,
and the symmetry.
A symmetry is when
you take your system
and you do something to it,
like a rotation or translation,
and it's a symmetry if it
doesn't change anything,
if the energy remains invariant.
So if the energy doesn't change
under this transformation,
we call that a symmetry.
And we also showed that
symmetries, or translations,
are generated by
unitary operators.
For example, my favorite
examples are the translate by L
operator, which is unitary.
And also e to the minus dxl.
And the boost by
q operator, which
similarly is e to the minus qdp.
And the time translation
operator, U sub t,
which is equal to e to the minus
i t over h bar energy operator.
OK?
So these are
transformation operators.
These are symmetry operators,
which translate you by L,
boost or speed you
up by momentum q,
evolve you forward in time t.
And they can all be expressed
as e to the unitary operator.
So this in particular
is l i over h bar p.
And this is similarly x.
And earlier we understood
the role of momentum
having to do translations
in the following way.
There's a beautiful
theorem about this.
If you take a system and
its translation invariant,
the classical statement
of Noether's theorem
is that there's a conserved
quantity associated
with that translation.
That conserved quantity
is the momentum.
And quantum mechanically,
the generator
of that transformation
the Hermitian operator
that goes upstairs
in the unitary
is the operator associated
to that conserved quantity,
associated to that observable.
You have translations.
There's a conserved
quantity, which is momentum.
And the thing that generates
translations, the operator that
generates translations, is the
operator representing momentum.
So each of these are going
to come up later in today,
and I just wanted to flag
them down before the moment.
OK, questions before we move on?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So you made the claim
that every unitary operator can
be expressed as p to
the eigenfunction.
PROFESSOR: OK, I should be a
little bit careful, but yes.
That's right.
AUDIENCE: But if I
take the [INAUDIBLE] I
should be able to
figure out what it is,
but you can't take
the [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The more
precise statement
is that any unitary--
any one parameter
family of unitary operators
can be expressed in that form.
And then you can
take a derivative.
And that's the theory
of [INAUDIBLE],
which is beyond the scope.
Let me make a very
specific statement, which
is that one parameter
of [INAUDIBLE]
unitary transformation.
So translations by l,
where you can vary l,
can be expressed in that form.
And that's a very
general statement.
OK, so with all that as
prelude, let's go back to 3D.
So in 3D, the energy operator--
so what's going to change?
Now instead of just having
position and its momentum,
we now also have-- I'll call
this P sub x-- we can also
have a y-coordinate and
we have a z-coordinate.
And each of them
has its momentum.
P sub z and P sub y.
And here's just a quick
practical question.
We know that x with Px
is equal to i h bar.
So what do you expect
to be true of x with y?
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: Why?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: What does
this equation tell you?
What is its physical content?
Well, that they
don't commute, good.
What does that tell
you physically?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: That there's
an uncertainty principle
connecting the two.
PROFESSOR: Excellent.
So that's one statement.
So the consequence of
this is that there's
an uncertainty principle.
Delta x delta Px must be greater
than or equal to h bar upon 2.
What's another way
of saying this?
Do there exist simultaneous
eigenfunctions of x and P?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No.
No simultaneous eigenfunctions.
OK, so you can't
have a definite value
of x and a definite value
of P simultaneously.
There's no such state.
It's not that you can't know.
It's that there's no such state.
Do you expect to be able
to know the position in x
and the position in
y simultaneously?
Sure.
OK, so this turns out to be 0.
And in some sense,
you can take that
as a definition of
quantum mechanics.
x and y need to be 0.
And similarly, Px
and Py commute.
The momenta are independent.
However, Py and y should
be equal to minus i h bar.
Good.
Exactly.
So the commutators
work out exactly
as you'd naively expect.
Every pair of position and its
momenta commute canonically
to i h bar.
And every pair of
coordinates commute to 0.
Every pair of
momenta commute to 0.
Cool?
So what kind of systems are
we going to interested in?
Well, we're going to be
interested in systems
where the energy
operator is equal to P
vector hat squared upon 2m plus
U of x and y and z, hat, hat.
You can see why dropping
the hats becomes almost /
So in this language, we can
write the Schrodinger equation.
This is just a direct extension
of the 1D Schrodinger equation.
i h bar dt of psi.
Now our wave function is a
function of x and y and z.
There's some finite
probability then
to find a particle
at some position.
That position is labeled
by the three coordinates.
Is equal to-- and of t.
Is equal to-- well,
I'm actually write
this in slightly different form.
This is going to be easier
if I use vector notation.
So I'm going to write
this as psi of r and t,
where r denotes the
position vector,
is equal to the energy
operator acting on it.
And P is just equal to
minus i h bar the gradient.
So this is minus i h bar
squared, or minus h bar squared
upon 2m gradient squared plus
u of x or now u of r psi of r
and t.
Quick question, what
are the units or what
are the dimensions
of psi of r in 3D?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, one over
length to the root three halves.
And the reason is this norm
squared gives us a probability
density, something
that when we integrated
over all positions in a
region integral d 3x is going
to give us a number,
a probability.
So its actual
magnitude must be--
or its dimension must
be 1 over L to the 3/2.
Just the cube of
what it was in 1D.
And as you'll see
on the problems set
and as we'll do in a couple
lectures down the road,
it's convenient sometimes
to work in Cartesian,
but it's also
sometimes convenient
to work in spherical
coordinates.
And it does not matter.
And here's a really
deep statement
that goes way beyond
quantum mechanics.
It does not matter which
coordinates you work in.
You cannot possibly get a
different answer by using
different coordinates.
So we're going to be ruthless
in exploiting coordinates that
will simplify our problem
throughout the rest
of this course.
In the notes is it a short
discussion of the form
of the Laplacian,
or the gradient
squared in Cartesian spherical
and cylindrical coordinates.
You should feel free to use
any coordinate system you
want at any point.
You just have to be
consistent about it.
So let's work out a
couple of examples.
And here are all
we're going to do
is apply exactly the same
logic that we see over
and over in 1D to
our 3D problems.
So the first example is
a free particle in 3D.
So before I get started
on this, any questions?
Just in general 3D questions?
OK.
So this stuff starts off easy.
And I'm going to work in
Cartesian coordinates.
And a fun problem is
to repeat this analysis
in spherical coordinates,
and we'll do that later on.
OK, so free particle
in 3D, so what
is the energy eigenfunction
equation look like?
We want to find-- the
Schrodinger equation has
exactly the same
structure as before.
It's a linear
differential equation.
So if we find the eigenfunctions
of the energy operator,
we can use superposition to
construct the general solution,
right?
So exactly as in 1D, I'm going
to construct first the energy
eigenfunctions , and then use
them in superposition to find
a general solution to
the Schrodinger equation.
OK?
So let's construct the
energy eigenfunctions.
So what is the energy
eigenvalue equation look like?
Well, E on psi is equal to
minus h bar squared upon 2m.
And in Cartesian, the
Laplacian is derivative respect
to x squared plus
derivative with respect
to y squared plus derivative
with respect to z squared.
And we have no potential,
so this is just psi.
So that would be energy
operator acting on it.
And the eigenvalue
equation is at a constant,
the energy E on psi
satisfies this equation.
I'm going to write
this phi sub e
to continue with
our notation of phi
being the energy eigenfunctions.
It of course, doesn't
matter what I call it,
but just for consistency I'm
going to use the letter phi.
So this is a very easy
equation to solve.
In particular, it has
a lovely property,
which is that it's separable.
OK?
So separable means
the following.
It means, look, I note, I just
observed that this differential
equation can be written
as a sum of terms
where there's a derivative with
respect to only one variable.
There's a differential
operator with respect
to only one variable and
another differential operator
with respect to only one
variable added together.
And when you see that,
you can separate.
And here's what I
mean by separate.
I'm going to just construct.
I'm not going to say that
this is a general solution.
I'm just going to
try to construct
a set of solutions of
the following form.
Psi E of x, y, and
z is equal to psi
E-- I will call this psi
sub x of x times phi sub
y of y times phi sub z of z.
And if we take this and we plug
it in, let's see what we get.
This gives us that E on phi E
is equal to minus h bar squared
upon 2m.
Well the dx squared
acting on phi sub e
is only going to hit this guy.
So I'm going to get phi x
prime prime phi y phi z.
Plus from the next term phi
y prime prime phi x phi z.
And from the next term phi
z prime prime phi x phi y.
But now I can do a sneaky thing
and divide the entire equation
by phi sub e.
Phi sub e is phi x phi y phi z.
So if I do so, I lose the phi
y phi z, and I divide by phi x.
And in this term, when I
divide by phi x phi y phi z,
I lose the x and z, and I have
a left over phi sub y, or phi y.
And similarly here,
phi sub z upon phi z.
Everyone cool with that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can we also
lose the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: I don't think so.
Minus h bar squared over 2m
just hangs out for the ride.
So when I take the
derivatives, I get these guys.
And I have E times the function.
We could certainly write
this as 2m over h bar squared
and put it over here.
That's fine.
OK, so this is the form
of the equation we have,
and what does this give us?
What content does this give us?
Well, note the following.
This is a funny system.
This is a function of x.
This is a function of y, g
of y only, and not of x or z.
And this is a function only
of z, and not of x or y.
Yeah?
So we have that E,
and let's put this
as minus 2m over
h bar squared is
equal to a function of
x plus a function of y
plus a function of h.
What does this tell you?
AUDIENCE: They're all constant.
PROFESSOR: They're
all constant, right.
So the important
thing is this equation
has to be true for every
value of x, y, and z.
It's a differential equation.
It's true everywhere.
It's true here.
It's true there.
It's true at every point.
Yeah?
So for any value of x, y, and
z, this equation must be true.
So now imagine I have a
particular solution g at h.
I'm going to fix y and z
to some particular point.
I'm going to look right here.
And here that fixes y and z.
So these are just some numbers.
And suppose we
satisfy this equation.
Then there's a very x
leaving y and z fixed.
What must be true of f of x?
AUDIENCE: Constant.
PROFESSOR: It's got to
be constant, exactly.
So this tells us that
f of x is a constant.
I.e.
phi x prime prime of
over phi x is a constant.
I'll call it epsilon x.
And phi y prime prime
of over phi y and this
is a function of y of x
is equal to epsilon y.
And actually for--
yeah, that's fine.
For fun I'm going
to put in a minus.
It doesn't matter what
I call this coefficient.
And similarly for phi z
prime prime z over phi z
is equal to minus epsilon z.
So this tells us that
minus 2m upon h bar squared
e is equal to minus epsilon x
minus epsilon y minus epsilon
z.
And any solutions
of these equations
with some constant value
of epsilon x, epsilon
y, and epsilon z
is going to give me
a solution of my original energy
eigenvalue equation, where
the value of capital
E is equal to the sum.
And I can take the minus
signs make this plus plus.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can
epsilon x, epsilon y,
and epsilon z-- can
one of them be negative
if the other's are sufficiently
positive or vice versa?
Or is that [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Let's check.
Let's check.
So what are the solutions
of this equation?
Yeah.
So solutions to
this equation phi
double-- so let's write this in
a slightly more familiar form.
This says that phi prime
prime plus epsilon x
phi is equal to 0, OK?
But this just tells you
that phi is exponential.
Phi is equal to a e
to the Ikx kxx plus B
e to the minus ikxx,
where k squared is
equal to kx squared
is equal to epsilon x.
OK?
So this becomes-- and similarly
for epsilon y and epsilon z,
each with their own
value of ky and kz
who squares the
epsilon accordingly.
So what can you say
about these epsilons?
Well, the epsilons are
strictly positive numbers.
So to answer your question.
So the epsilons
have to be positive.
OK, so this equation becomes,
though, E is equal to-- I'm
going to put the h bar squared
over 2m back on the other side.
h bar squared upon 2m.
Epsilon x, epsilon y, epsilon z.
But those are just
Kx squared plus Ky
squared plus Kz squared.
Kx squared plus
Ky squared plus Kz
squared, also known as
h bar squared upon 2m k
vector squared, where the
wave function, phi sub
E is equal to some overall
normalization constant times,
for the first function--
where did the definition go?
Right here.
So from here, phi x is
the exponential with Kx.
This is an
exponential y with Ky.
And then the exponential
in z with Kz.
e to the ikx times x plus
Ky times y plus Kz times z.
Let me write this as e to the i.
e to the i.
Also known as some normalization
constant e to the i k vector
dot r vector.
OK?
So the energy, if we have
a free particle, the energy
eigenfunctions can
be put in the form,
or at least we can build energy
eigenfunctions of the form,
plane waves with some 3D
momentum with energy E
is equal to h bar squared
k squared upon 2m,
just as we saw for the free
particle in one dimension.
And the actual wave
function is nothing
but a product of
wave functions in 1D.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What happened
to the minus ikx minus iky
minus ikz terms?
PROFESSOR: Good, so here
I just dropped these guys.
So I just picked examples where
we just picked e to the ikz.
That's an excellent question.
So I've done something here.
In particular, I looked
at a special case.
And here's an important
lesson from the theory
of the separable
equations, which
is that once I separate-- so
if I have a separable equation
and I find it
separated solution,
phi E is equal to phi x of
x, phi y of y phi z of z,
not all functions-- not all
solutions of the equation
are of this form.
They're not.
I had to make that assumption.
I said suppose it's of
this form right here.
So this is an assumption.
OK?
However, these
form a good basis.
By taking suitable
linear combinations
of them, suitable
super positions,
I can build a completely
general solution.
For example, as was noted, the
true solution of this equation,
even just focusing on
the x, is a superposition
of plus and minus
waves, waves with
plus positive negative momentum.
So how do we get that?
Well, we could
write that as phi is
equal to e to the ikx
phi y phi z plus e
to the minus ikx phi y phi z
with the same phi y and phi z.
So these are actually in there.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: My other
question is so I still
don't see why any
of the epsilons
can't have a negative sign.
You have an exponential,
a real exponential as one
of your products.
PROFESSOR: OK, so if we
had a negative epsilon,
is that wave function
going to be normalizable?
AUDIENCE: Oh, as r
goes to-- but can you
just keep the minus term?
PROFESSOR: In which direction?
AUDIENCE: Oh, right.
PROFESSOR: So if it's
converging in this direction,
it's got to be growing
in this direction.
And that's not going
to be normalizable.
And so as usual
with the plane wave,
we can pick the oscillating
solutions that are also
not normalizable
to one, but they're
delta function normalizable.
And so that's what
we've done here.
It's exactly the
same thing as in 1D.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So does this mean
that any superposition of plane
waves with wave vector
equal in magnitude
will also be an eigenfunction
of the same energy?
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
Awesome.
Great observation.
So the observation is this.
Suppose I take K,
I'll call it K1.
So this is a vector
such that K1 squared
times h bar squared
over 2m is equal to E.
Now there are many vectors k
which have the same magnitude,
but not the same direction.
So we could also make this equal
to h bar squared K2 squared
vector squared over 2m where K2
is not equal to K1 as a vector,
although they share
the same magnitude.
So that's interesting.
So that looks a lot like before.
In 1D, we saw that if
we have k or minus k,
these have the same energy.
All right?
Now if we have any K,
K1-- so this is 1D.
In 3D, if we have K1 and
K2 with the same magnitude
and the same energy,
they're degenerate.
That's interesting.
Why?
Why do we have this
gigantic degeneracy
of the energy eigenfunctions
for the free particle in three
dimensions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well, there
are an infinite number
of directions it could be going
in with the same momentum.
PROFESSOR: Awesome.
So this is clearly true that
there are an infinite number
of momenta with
the same magnitude.
So there are many,
many, but why?
Why do they have
the same energy?
Couldn't they have
different energy?
Couldn't this one have
a different energy?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Excellent,
it's symmetric.
The system is invariant
under rotation.
Who are you to say this
is the x direction?
I call it y.
Right?
So the system has a symmetry.
The symmetry is rotations.
And when we have
a symmetry, that
means there's an operator,
a unitary operator, which
affects that rotation,
the rotation operator.
It's the operator
that takes a vector
and rotates in some
particular way.
We have a unitary
operator that's
a symmetry that means it
commutes with the energy
operator.
But if it commutes with
the energy operator,
we get can degeneracies.
We can get states that are
different states mapped
to each other under our unitary
operator, under our rotation.
We get states which are
different states manifestly.
But which have the
same energy, which
are shared energy eigenvalues.
Cool?
And this is a really lovely
example, both in 1D and 3D,
that when you have a symmetry,
you get degeneracies.
And when you have
a degeneracy, you
should be very
suspicious that there's
a symmetry hanging around,
lurking around ensuring it, OK?
And this is an
important general lesson
that goes way beyond the
specifics of the free particle.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So that
occurs in systems
with bound states [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it occurs
in systems with bound states
and systems with
non bound states.
So here we're talking
about a free particle.
Certainly not bound.
And its true.
For bound states, we'll
also see that there
will be a degeneracy
associated with symmetry.
Now your question is a
really, really good one,
because what we found-- let
me rephrase the question.
The question is, look, in
1D when we had bound states,
there was no degeneracy.
Didn't matter what
you did to the system.
When you had bound states, bound
states were non degenerate.
In 3D, we see that when
you have a free particle,
you again get degeneracy.
In fact, you get a heck
of a lot more degeneracy.
You get a sphere's worth.
Although actually, that's a
sphere in 0 dimension, right?
It's a 0 dimensional
sphere, two points.
So you get a sphere's
worth of degenerate states
for the free particle.
Well, what about bound states?
Are bound states non
degenerate still?
Fantastic question.
Let's find out.
So let's do the
harmonic oscillator.
Let's do the 3D harmonic
oscillator to check.
So the 3D harmonic oscillator,
the potential is h bar squared.
And let's pick for fun the
rotationally symmetric 3D
harmonic oscillator.
m omega squared upon 2 x squared
plus y squared plus z squared.
This could also be written m
omega squared upon 2 r squared.
So I could write it in
spherical coordinates
or in Cartesian coordinates.
This is really in
vector notation.
Doesn't matter.
It's the same thing.
3D harmonic oscillator.
So what you immediately deduce
about the form of the energy
eigenfunctions?
Well, we have that E phi E
is equal to P squared over
minus h bar squared
over 2m-- so here's
the energy eigenvalue
equation-- times
dx squared plus dy squared plus
dz squared plus m omega squared
upon 2 times x squared plus y
squared plus z squared phi E.
But I can put this
together in a nice way.
This is minus h bar
squared upon 2m dx squared
plus m omega squared upon 2
x squared plus ditto for y
plus ditto for z phi E. Yeah?
Everyone agree?
So this is differential
operator that only involves x.
Doesn't involve y or z.
Ditto y, but no x or z.
And ditto z, but no x or y.
Aha, this is separable
just as before.
So now we have a
nice separable system
where I want to solve the
equations 3 times, once
for x, y, and z.
And I'm just going
to write it for x, y,
and z epsilon sub x phi x is
equal to minus h bar squared
over 2m dx squared plus
m omega squared upon 2 x
squared phi sub x.
And ditto for x, y, z.
And then phi E is going
to be equal to phi
x of x, phi y of y,
and phi z of z, OK?
Where E is equal to epsilon x
plus epsilon y plus epsilon z.
Note that I've used a slightly
different definition of epsilon
here as before.
Here it's explicitly
the energy eigenvalue.
So what this is
telling is, look,
we know what this equation is.
This equation is
the same equation
we ran into in the 1D
harmonic oscillator.
It's exactly the 1D
harmonic oscillator problem.
So the solution to the 3D
harmonic oscillator problem
can be written for
energy eigenfunctions,
can be constructed
by taking a harmonic
oscillator in the x direction--
and we know what those are.
There's a tower of them.
There's a ladder of them
created by the raising operator
and lowered by the
lowering operator.
And similarly for y,
and similarly for z.
So I'm going to write
this slightly differently
in the same place as phi sub
E is equal to phi sub nx of x.
The state with energy E sub nx.
Phi sub ny of y.
Phi sub nz of z.
Where these are all
the single dimension,
one dimensional harmonic
oscillator eigenfunctions.
And E is equal to Ex E sub nx
plus E sub ny plus E sub nz.
OK?
So let's look at the
consequences of this.
So first off, does anyone
have any questions?
I went through
the kind of quick.
Any questions about that?
If you're not comfortable
with separable equations,
you need to become super
comfortable with separable
equations.
It's an important technique.
We're going to use it a lot.
So the upshot is that
if I write-- in fact,
I'm going to write that in
slightly different notation.
If I write phi E
is equal to phi n
of x, where it's the-- and phi
l of y and phi m of z-- actually
that's a stupid ordering.
Let's try that again.
l, m, n.
That is the
alphabetical ordering.
With the energy is
now equal to-- we
know the energy is of a
state with of the harmonic
oscillator with
excitation number l.
It's h bar omega, the overall
omega, times l plus 1/2.
But from this guy it's
got excitation number m,
so energy of that is h bar
omega m plus 1/2 plus m.
And so now that's plus 1.
And for this guy
similarly, h bar omega
n plus n and now plus
1/2 again plus 3/2.
This is a basis of solutions
of the energy eigenfunction
equations.
These are the solutions of
the energy eigenfunctions
for the 3D harmonic oscillator.
And now here's the question.
The question that
was asked is, look,
there are no degeneracies
in bound states in 1D.
Here we have manifestly
a 3D bound state system.
Are there degeneracies?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
obviously, right?
So for example, if I call
l1 this 0 and this 0.
Or if I call this 010 or 001,
those all have the same energy.
They have the energy h bar
omega 0 times 1 plus 3/2 or 5/2.
So let's look at this
in a little more detail.
Let's write a list
of the degeneracies
as a function of the energy.
So at energy what's
the ground state energy
for the 3D harmonic oscillator?
3 halves h bar omega.
It's three times
the ground state
energy for the single
1D harmonic oscillator.
So 3/2 h bar omega.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Good, the way
we arrived that this was we
found that the energy-- so
the energy operator acting
on the 3D wave
function is what I
get by taking the
energy operator in 1D
and acting on the wave function,
and the energy operator in y
acting on the wave function,
the energy operator in z acting
on the wave function, where
the energy operator for each
of those is the 1D
harmonic oscillator
with the same frequency.
OK?
And then I separated.
I said look, let
the wave function,
the 3D wave function, since
I know this is separable
and each separated part
of the wave function
satisfies the 1D harmonic
oscillator equation,
I know what the eigenfunctions
of the 1D harmonic oscillator
energy eigenvalue problem are.
They are the phi n's.
And so I can just take
my 3D wave function.
I can say the 3D wave function
is going to be the separated
form, the product
of 1D wave function
in x, a 1D wave function in
y, and 1D wave function in z.
Cool?
So now let's look back
at what let's think
about what happens when I
take the energy operator
and I act on that [INAUDIBLE].
When I take the 3D
energy operator, which
is the sum of the three
1D energy operators,
harmonic oscillator
energy operators.
When thinking I'm going
to act on this guy,
the first one, which only
knows about the x direction,
sees the y and z
parts as constants.
And it's a phi x, and
what does it give us back?
E on phi x is just h bar
omega n plus one half.
Ditto for this guy.
And then the energy
operator in 3D
is the sum of the three
1D energy operators.
So that tells us the energy is
the sum of the three energies.
Is that cool?
OK good.
Other questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is the number of
degeneracies essentially
[INAUDIBLE] of number theory.
PROFESSOR: Ask me
that after class.
So let's look at
the degeneracies
as a function of the energy.
So at the lowest possible
energy, 3/2 omega, what states
can I possibly have?
I'm going to label the states by
the three numbers, l, m, and n.
So this is just the
ground state 0 0 0.
So is that degenerate?
No, because there's
just the one state.
What about at the next level?
What's the next allowed energy?
AUDIENCE: 5/2.
PROFESSOR: 5/2.
OK, 5/2.
So at 5/2 what
states do we have?
Well, we have 1 0 0.
But we also have 0, 1, 0.
And we also 0 0 1.
Aha, this is looking good.
What does this
correspond to physically?
This says you have
excitation, so you've
got a node in the x direction.
But your Gaussian in
the y and z directions.
This one says your Gaussian
in the x direction.
You have a node in the y
direction as a function of y,
because it's phi 1 of y.
And you're Gaussian
in the z directions.
And this one says you have 1
excitation in the z direction.
So they sound sort of
rotated from each other.
That sounds promising.
But in particular, what
we just discovered sort of
by construction
is that there can
be degeneracies among
bound states in 3D.
This was not possible
in 1D, but it
is possible in
3D, which is cool.
But we've actually learned more.
What's the form of
the degeneracies?
So here it looks like they're
just rotations of each other.
You call this x, I call it
y, someone else calls it z.
These can't possibly
look different functions
because they're just
rotations of each other.
However, things get
a little more messy
when you write, well,
what's the next level?
What's the next energy
after 5/2 h bar omega?
7/2 h bar omega, exactly.
7/2.
And that's not so bad.
So for that one, we get
2 0 0, 0 2 0, 0 0 2.
But is that it?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: What else do we get?
1 1 0, 0 1 1, 1 0 1.
So first off, let's
look at the number.
The degeneracy number
here-- I'll call this d sub
0-- the degeneracy of the
ground state is 1, OK?
The degeneracy--
and in fact, I'm
going to write this as a table--
the degeneracy as level n.
So for d0 is equal to 1.
d1 is equal to 3.
And d2 is equal to 6.
Now it's less clear
here what's going on,
because is this just
this guy relabelled?
No.
So this is weird,
because we already
said that the reason we expect
that there might be degeneracy,
is because of
rotational symmetry.
The system is
rotationally invariant.
The potential, which is the
harmonic oscillator potential,
doesn't care in what direction
the radial displacement
vector is pointing.
It's rotationally symmetrical.
When we have symmetry--
on general grounds, when
we have a symmetry, we
expect to have degeneracies.
But this are kind of
weird, because these
don't seem to be simple
rotations of each other,
and yet they're degenerate.
So what's up with that?
Question?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] Gaussian
in certain directions?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, sure OK.
So let me just explain what
this notation means again.
So by 1 0 0, what I mean is
that the number l is equal to 1,
the number m is equal
to 0, n is equal to 0.
That means that
the wave function
phi 3D is equal to phi 1 of
x, phi 0 of y, phi 0 of z.
But what's phi 0 of z?
What's a Gaussian
in the z direction?
Phi 0 of y.
That's the ground state
in the y direction
of the harmonic oscillator.
It's Gaussian in
the y direction.
If I wanted x, that's
not the ground state.
That's the excited state.
And in particular, sort of being
a Gaussian it goes through 0.
It has a node.
So this wave function is
not rotationally invariant.
It as a node in the x direction,
but no nodes and y and z
direction.
And similarly for these guys.
Did that answer your questions?
Great.
OK, so we have
these degeneracies,
and they beg an explanation.
And if you look
at the next level,
it turns out that d3-- and
you can do this quickly
on a scrap of
paper-- d3 is 10, OK?
And they go on.
And if you keep
writing this list out,
I guess it goes up--
what's the next one?
15.
21, yeah.
So this has a simple
mathematical structure,
and you can very quickly
convince yourself
of the form of this degeneracy.
dn is n n plus 1 over 2.
So let's just make
sure that works.
1 1 plus 1 over 2.
Sorry I should
really call this 1.
n plus 1, n plus 2
if I count from 0.
So for 0, this is going to
give us 1 times 2 over 2.
That's 1.
That works.
So for 1 that gives
2 times 3 over 2,
which is 3, and so
on and so forth.
So where did this come from?
This is something we're
going to have to answer.
Why that degeneracy?
That seems important.
Why is it that number?
Why do we have that
much degeneracy?
But the thing I really want
to emphasize at this point
is that there's an absolutely
essential deep connection
between symmetries
and degeneracies.
If we didn't have symmetry,
we wouldn't have degeneracy,
and we can see that
very easily here.
Imagine that this potential
was not exactly symmetric.
Imagine we made it slightly
different by adding
a little bit of extra
frequency to z direction.
Make the z frequency
slightly different.
Plus m omega tilde
squared upon 2 z
squared, where omega tilde
is not equal to omega 0.
OK?
The system is still
separable, but this guy
has frequency omega 0.
The x part has omega 0.
This has omega 0.
But this has omega tilde.
OK?
And so exactly the same
argument is going to go through,
but the energy now is going
to have a different form.
The energy is going to have h
bar omega-- h bar omega 0 times
l plus m plus 1.
But from the z part
it's going to have
plus h bar omega tilde
times n plus 1/2.
And now these
degeneracies are going
to be broken, because
this state will not
have the same
energy as these two.
Everyone see that?
When you have symmetry,
you get to degeneracy.
When you don't have a symmetry,
you do not get degeneracy.
This connection is
extremely important,
because it allows
you to do two things.
It allows you to
first not solve things
you don't need to solve for.
If you know there's a symmetry,
solve it once and then compute
the degeneracy and you're done.
On the other hand,
if you have a system
and you see just manifestly
you measure the energies,
and you measure that the
energies are degenerate,
you know there's a symmetry
protecting those degeneracies.
You actually can't
be 100% confident,
because I didn't prove
that these are related
to each other, but you
should be highly suspicious.
And in fact, this is an
incredibly powerful tool
in building models
of physical systems.
If you see a degeneracy or
an approximate degeneracy,
you can exploit that to learn
things about the underlying
system.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So we just
add the different omega
to each omega
[INAUDIBLE] number there
is still a possibility
to get a degeneracy.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So it's possible for these
omegas to be specially tuned
so that rational combinations
of them give you a degeneracy.
But it's extraordinarily
unlikely for that
to happen accidentally,
because they
have to be rationally
related to each other,
and the rationals are a set
of measures 0 in the reels.
So if you just randomly
pick some frequencies,
they'll be totally
incommensurate,
and you'll never
get a degeneracy.
So it is possible to have
an accidental degeneracy.
Whoops, just pure coincidence.
But it's extraordinarily
unlikely.
And as you'll see when you
get to perturbation theory,
it's more than unlikely.
It's almost impossible.
So it's very rare that you
get accidental degeneracy.
It happens, but it's rare.
Other questions?
OK, nothing?
OK so here we're now
going to launch into--
so this leads us into
a very simple question.
At the end of the
day, the degeneracies
that we see for the 3D
free particle, which
is a whole sphere's
worth of degeneracy,
and the degeneracy we see for
the 3D harmonic oscillator,
the bound states,
which is discrete,
but with more and
more degeneracy
the higher and
higher energy you go.
Those we're blaming,
at the moment,
on a symmetry, on
rotational symmetry,
rotational invariance.
So it seems wise
to study rotations,
to study rotational invariance
and rotational transformations
in the first place.
In the first part of the
course, in 1D quantum mechanics,
we got an awful lot of juice
out of studying translations.
And the generator of
translations was momentum.
So we're going to do
the same thing now.
We're going to study
rotations and the generators
of rotations, which are the
angular momentum operators,
and that's going to occupy
us for the rest of today
and Thursday.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So your
rotational symmetry
will explain a factor of three
in your degeneracy, right?
But what's the symmetry that
explains the way this grows.
Because this very
clearly appears
there's 1 up to a
factor of three.
And then there's 2 up
to a factor of three.
And there's even more that's
not even a multiple of three.
PROFESSOR: Right,
actually so here's
a very tempting
bit of intuition.
Very tempting bit of intuition
is going to say the following.
Look, rotational invariance,
there's x, there's y,
and there's z.
It's going to explain
rotations amongst those three.
So that could only possibly
give you a factor of three.
But it's important
to keep in mind
that that's not
correct intuition.
It's tempting intuition,
but it's not correct.
And an easy way to see
that its not correct
is that for the
free particle, there
is a continuum, a
whole sphere's worth
of degenerate states
in any energy.
And all of those are related to
each other by simple rotation
of the k vector, of
the wave vector, right?
So the rotational
symmetry is giving us
a lot more than a
factor of three.
And in fact, as
we'll see, it's going
to explain exactly the n
plus 1 n plus 2 over 2.
OK, so with that
motivation let's
start talking about
angular momentum.
So I found this topic
to be not obviously
the most powerful or interesting
thing in the world when I first
studied it.
And my professor
was like no, no, no.
This is the deepest thing.
And recently I had a fun
conversation with one
of my colleagues,
Frank Wilczeck,
who said yeah, in intro
to quantum mechanics
the single most interesting
thing is the angular momentum
and the addition of
angular momentum.
And something has happened to
me in the intervening 20 years
that I totally agree with him.
So I will attempt to convey to
you the awesomeness of this.
But you have to buy in a little.
So work with me in the math
at the beginning of this,
and it has a great payoff.
OK so the question is,
what is the operator.
So we're going to talk
about angular momentum now.
And I want to start with
the following question.
In the same sense
as we started out
by asking what
represents position
and momentum, linear momentum,
in quantum mechanics, what
represents what operator by
our first, second, or third
postulate-- I don't even
remember the order now.
What operator represents angular
momentum in quantum mechanics?
And let's start by remembering
what angular momentum is
in classical mechanics.
So L in classical
mechanics is r cross p.
In classical mechanics.
So let's just try this.
Let's construct that operator.
This is not the world's most
beautiful way of deriving this,
but let's just write
down natural guess.
For in quantum mechanics
what's the operator we want?
Well, we want a vectors
worth of operators,
because angular
momentum is a vector.
It's a vector of
operators, three operators.
And I'm going to write these
as r vector the operators x, y,
z cross p the vector
of momentum operators.
So at this point, you
should really worry,
because do r and p commute?
Not so much, right?
However, the situation is
better than it first appears.
Let's write this out
in terms of components.
So this is in components.
And I'm going to
work, for the moment,
in Cartesian coordinates.
So Lx is equal to?
Lx is equal to?
You all took mechanics.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
YPz minus ZPy.
And that's the curl, the
x component of the curl.
And similarly, the x component--
so the way to remember this
is that its cyclic.
x, y, z.
y, z, x.
So z, p, y.
PX minus XPz.
And then we have
z XPy minus YPx.
So we were worried here about
maybe an ordering problem.
Is there an ordering
problem here?
Does it matter if
I write YPz or PZy?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No, because they
commute with each other.
PZ is momentum for
the z-coordinate, not
the y-coordinate, and they
commute with each other.
So there's no ambiguity.
It's perfectly well defined.
So we're just going
to take this to be
the definition of the components
of the angular momentum
operator Lx, Ly, and Lz.
And just for fun, I
want to write this out.
So because we know that Px,
Py, and Pz can be expressed
in terms of derivatives
or differential operators,
we can write the same operator
in Cartesian coordinates
in the following way.
So clearly we could
write this as Y d dx i
upon h bar-- or
sorry, h bar upon i.
And z h bar upon i d dy.
So we could write that
in Cartesian coordinates
as a differential operator.
But we can also write this
in spherical coordinates.
I'm just going to take
a quick side note just
to write down what it is.
If we did this
spherical coordinates,
it's particularly
convenient to write--
let me just write
Lz for the moment.
This is equal to minus i h bar
derivative with respect to phi,
where the coordinates,
[INAUDIBLE]
coordinates and spherical
coordinates in this class
is theta is going
to be the angle down
from the vertical
axis, from the z-axis.
And phi is going to be
the angle of a period 2pi
that goes around
the equator, OK?
Just to give you a name.
This is typically what
physicists call them.
This is typically not what
mathematicians call them.
This leads to
enormous confusion.
I apologize for my field.
So here it is.
I can also construct
the operator associated
with the square of the momentum.
And why would we care about
the square of the momentum?
Well, that's what shows up
in the Hamiltonian, that's
what shows up in the energy.
So I can construct the operator
for the square of the momentum
and write it, and it takes
a surprisingly simple form.
When I see surprisingly simple,
you might disagree with me,
but if you actually do
the derivation of this,
it's much worse in between.
1 over sine theta
d theta sine theta
d theta plus 1 over sine
squared theta d phi.
Couple quick things.
What are the dimensions
of angular momentum?
Length and momentum.
What else has units
of angular momentum?
AUDIENCE: h bar.
PROFESSOR: Solid. h
bar, dimensionless.
Angular momentum squared,
angular momentum squared.
OK, great.
So that's going to
be very convenient.
h bars are just going to
float around willy nilly.
OK, so suppose I ask you
the following-- bless you.
Suppose I ask you the
following questions.
I say look, here are the
operators of angular momentum.
This is Lz.
We could have written down
the same expression for Lx,
and a Ly, and L squared.
What are the eigenfunctions
of these operators?
Suppose I ask you this question.
You all know how to
answer this question.
You take these operators--
so for example,
if I ask you what are
the eigenfunctions of Lz?
Well, that's not so bad, right?
The eigenfunction
of Lz is something
where Lz on phi--
I'll call little m--
is equal to minus I h
bar d d theta phi sub m.
But I want the
eigenvalue, so I'll
call this h bar
times some number.
Let's call it m, because
Lz is an angular momentum.
It carries units of
h bar, and its h bar
times some number which is
dimensional, so we'll call it
m.
And we all know the
solution of this equation.
The derivative is equal
to a constant times--
we can lose the h bar.
We get a minus i,
so we pick up an i.
So therefore phi sub m is
equal to some constant times e
to the im phi.
What can we say about m?
Well, heres an important
thing-- oh shoot.
I'm using phi in so many
different ways here.
Let's call this not
phi, because it's
going to confuse
the heck out of us.
Let's call it Y. So
we'll call it Y sub m.
Why not?
It's not my joke.
This goes back to a bunch of--
yeah well, it goes way back.
So phi is the variable.
Y is the deciding eigenfunction
of Lz, and that's great.
But what can you say about m?
Well phi is the variable
around the equator
is periodic with period 2pi.
And our wave function had
better be single valued.
So what does that
tell you about m?
Well, under phi goes
to phi plus 2pi.
This shifts by im 2pi.
And that's only one to
make a single valued
if m is an integer.
So m has to be an integer.
m is an integer.
Now we did that for Lz.
We found the
eigenfunctions of Lz.
What about finding the
eigenfunctions L squared?
Exactly the same thing.
We're going to solve
the eigenvalue equation,
but it's going to be
horrible, horrible to find
these functions, right?
Because look at this.
1 over sine squared d d phi.
And then 1 over sine
d theta sine d theta.
This is not going to
be a fun thing to do.
So we could just brute
force this, but let's not.
Let's all agree that
that's probably a bad idea.
Let's find a better way to
construct the eigenfunctions
of the angular
momentum operators.
So let's do it.
So we ran into a
situation like this
before when we dealt with
the harmonic oscillator.
There was a
differential equation
that we wanted to solve.
And OK, this one isn't nearly
as bad, not nearly as bad
as that one would have been.
But still it was more useful
to work with operator methods.
So let's take a hint from that
and work with operator methods.
So now we need to study the
operators of angular momentum.
So let's study them in
a little more detail.
So something you're going
to show in your problem set
is the following.
The commutator of Lx with Ly
takes a really simple form.
This is equal to i h bar--
let's just do this out.
Let's do this commutator.
We're OK.
So Lx with Ly, this is
equal to the commutator
of YPz minus ZPy with
Ly ZPx minus XPz.
So let's look at
these term by term.
So the first one is YPz ZPx.
YPz ZPx.
That's a Px.
Sorry, ZPy.
ZPx, this term.
X, good.
That's the first commutator.
The second commutator, it can
be YPz an XPz minus YPz XPz.
And then these
commutators, the next two,
are going to be ZPy with ZPx.
And finally ZPy.
And that's minus
and this is a plus.
ZPy and XPz.
OK, so let's look at these.
These look kind
of scary at first.
But in this one
notice the following.
This is XPz ZPx minus ZPx YPz.
But what you say about Y with
all these other operators?
Y commutes with all of them.
So in each term I
could just pull Y
all the way out to one side.
Yeah?
So I could just pull out this
Y. So for the first term,
I'm going to write this as
Y commutator PZ with ZPx.
And let me just do
that explicitly.
There's no reason to.
So this is YPz
ZPx minus ZPx YPz.
And I can pull the Y out front,
because this commutes with Px
and with Z. So I can make this
Y times PZ ZPx minus ZPx Pz.
But now note that I can
do exactly the same thing
with the Px.
Px commutes with z.
Px commutes with Pz.
And it commutes with y.
So I can pull the px
from each term out.
Px Y. And now I lose the Px.
I lose the Px.
But now this is looking good.
This is Px times Y. And Pz
minus ZPz PZz minus ZPz.
This is also known as PXy
times commutator of PZ with Z.
And what is this equal to?
Let's get our signs right.
This is Px with Y
time-- OK, we all
agree that this is going
to have an h bar in it.
Let's write units.
There's going to be an i.
And is it a plus or minus?
Minus.
OK, good.
So we get minus h bar XPy.
So this term is going to give
us minus i h bar Py XPx times Y.
And let's look at this term.
OK, this is Y, and Y commutes
with PZx and PZ, right?
So I could just pull out the y.
And x commutes with everything,
so I can pull out the x.
And I'm left with the
commutator of Pz with Pz.
What's the commutator
of Pz with Pz?
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: 0.
This term gives me a 0.
Similarly here, Py
commutes with everything.
Z ZPx.
Px commutes with everything.
Z ZPy.
So I can pull out the Px Py,
and I get Z commutator Z,
and what's that?
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: 0.
So this gives me 0.
And now this term, ZPy
XPz, the only two things
that don't commute with each
other are the Z and the Pz.
The Py and the X
I pull out, so I
get it a term that's XPy and
the commutator of Z with Pz.
And what is that
going to give me?
PyX i h bar.
Aha, look at what we got.
This is equal to i h bar times--
did I screw up the signs?
XPy minus YPz.
Oh sorry, Px.
And what is this equal to?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, i h bar Lz.
And more generally, as you'll
show on the problem set,
you get the following
commutators.
Once you've done this once, you
can do the rest very easily.
Lx Ly is-- so Lx with
Ly is i h bar Lz.
And then the rest can be
got from cyclic rotations
Ly with Lz is i h bar Lx and
Lz with Lx is i h bar Ly.
And now here's a fancier one.
This is less obvious, but
exactly the same machinations
will give you this result,
and you'll do this again
on the problems set.
If I take L squared,
k and L squared
here is going to be
L squared, I just
mean Lx squared plus Ly
squared plus Lz squared.
This is the norm squared of
the vector, the operator form.
L squared with Lz--
or sorry, with Lx.
Yeah, fine.
Lx is equal to 0.
So Lx commutes with the
magnitude L squared.
Similarly L squared, now just
by rotational invariance,
if Lx commutes
with it, Ly and Lz
had better also commute
with it, because
of who you to see what's Lx.
And L squared with Lz
must be equal to 0.
Yeah?
Everyone cool with that?
And the thing is
we've just-- and I'm
going to put big
flags around this.
We've just learned
a tremendous amount
about the eigenfunctions of
the angular momentum operators.
Why?
Let's leave that up.
So what have we just learned
about the eigenfunctions
of the angular momentum
operators Lx, Ly, Lz, and L
squared?
Anyone?
We just learned something
totally awesome about them.
Anyone?
So can you find simultaneous
eigenfunctions of Lx and Ly?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: Not so much.
They don't commute to 0.
What about Ly and Lz?
Nope.
Lz Lx, nope.
So you cannot find simultaneous
eigenfunctions of Lx and Ly.
What about Lx and L squared?
Yes.
So we can find
simultaneously eigenfunctions
of L squared and Lx.
OK, what about can we find
simultaneous eigenfunctions
of L squared and Ly?
Yep.
Exactly.
What about L
squared, Ly, and Lz?
Nope.
No such luck.
And this leads us to
the following idea.
The idea is a complete set
of commuting observables.
And here's what this
idea is meant to contain.
You can always write
down a lot of operators.
So let me step back and
ask a classical question.
Classically, suppose I have a
particle in three dimensions,
a particle moving around in
this room, non relativistic,
familiar 801.
I have a particle moving
around in this room.
How much data must
I specify to specify
the configuration
of this system?
Well, I have to tell you
where the particle is,
and I have to tell you what
its momentum is, right?
So I have to tell you the
three coordinates and the three
momenta.
If I give you five numbers,
that's not enough, right?
I need to give you
six bits of data.
On the other hand, if I
give you seven numbers,
like I give x, y, z, Px, Py,
Pz, and e, that's over complete.
Right?
That was unnecessary.
So in classical
mechanics, you can
ask what data must you
specify to completely specify
the state of the system.
And that's usually pretty easy.
You specify the
number coordinates
and the number of momenta.
In quantum mechanics, we ask
a slightly different question.
We ask, in order to specify
the state of a system,
we say we want to specify
which state it is.
You can specify
that by saying which
superposition in a
particular basis.
So you pick a basis,
and you specify
which particular
superposition, what
are the eigenvalues of
the operators you've
diagonalized in that basis?
So another way to phrase
this is for a 1D problem,
say we have just a
simple 1D problem.
We have X and we have P. What
is a complete set of commuting
operators?
Well, you have to
have enough operators
so that the eigenvalue
specifies a state.
So X would be-- is that enough?
So if I take the operator
X and I say look,
my system is in the state
with an eigenvalue X not of X,
does that specify the
state of the system?
It tells you the particles
are in a delta function state
right here.
Does that specify the state?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Fantastic, it does.
Now what if I tell
you instead, oh it's
in a state of definite P.
Does that specify the state?
Absolutely.
Can I say it's in a state with
definite X and definite P?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No.
These don't commute.
So a complete set of commuting
observables in this case
would be either X
or P, but not both.
Yeah?
Now if we're in three
dimensions, is x a complete set
of commuting observables?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No, because
it's not enough.
You tell me that it's
X, that doesn't tell me
what state it is
because it could
have y dependence
or z dependence.
So in 3D, we take, for
example, x, and y, and z.
Or Px, and Py, and Pz.
We could also pick
z, and Px, and y.
Are these complete?
If I tell you I have
definite position in z,
definite position in y,
and definite momentum in x?
Does that completely
specify my state?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
totally unambiguously.
e to the ikx delta of y delta
of z totally fixes my function,
completely specifies it.
If I'd only picked
two of these, it
would not have been complete.
It would have told
me, for example,
e to the ikx delta of y,
but it doesn't tell me
how it depends on z, how
the wave functions on z.
And if I added another
operator, for example, Py,
this is no longer commuting.
These two operators
don't commute.
So a complete set of
commuting observables
can be thought of as
the most operators
you can write down that
all commute with each other
and the minimum number
whose eigenvalues completely
specify the state of the system.
Cool?
OK.
So with all that said,
what is a complete set
of commuting observables for
the angular momentum system?
Well, it can't be any
two of Lx, Ly, and Lz.
So let's just pick one.
I'll call it Lz.
I could've called it Lx.
It doesn't matter.
It's up to you
what axis is what.
I'll just call it
Lz conventionally.
And then L squared
also commutes,
because L squared
commutes with Lx.
It commutes Ly and with Lz.
So this actually
forms a complete set
of commuting observables for
the angular momentum system.
Complete set of
commuting observables
for angular momentum.
So this idea will come
up more in the future.
And here is going to
be the key [INAUDIBLE].
So we'd like to use
the following fact.
We want to construct
the eigenfunctions
of our complete set
of-- yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: Really
quick can you explain
how you got that L
squared and Lx commute?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I
got it by knowing
what you're going to write
on your solution set.
So this is on your problem set.
So the way it goes-- so there
are fancy ways of doing it,
but the just direct
way of doing,
how do you construct
these commutators?
Is you know what
the operators are.
You know what L squared is.
And you know that L
squared is Lx squared
plus Ly squared plus Lz squared.
It's built in that
fashion out of x and Py.
And then I literally just put
in the definitions of Lx, Ly,
and Lz into that
expression for L squared
and compute the
commutator with Lx, again,
using the definition
in terms of Py and z.
And then you just chug
through the commutators.
Yeah, it just works out.
So it's not obvious from
the way I just phrased it
that it works out like that.
Later on you'll probably
develop some intuition
that it should be obvious.
But for the moment,
I'm just going
to call it a brute
force computation.
And that's how you're going
to do it on your problem set.
So let me tell you
where we're going next.
So the question I
really want to deal with
is what are the eigenfunctions?
So this is where
we're leaving off.
What are the eigenfunctions
of our complete set
of commuting variable
L squared and Lz.
What are these guys?
And we know that
we could solve them
by solving the differential
equations using
those operators, but
that would be horrible.
We'd like to do something
a little smarter.
We'd like to use the commutation
relations and the algebra.
And here a really beautiful
thing is going to happen.
When you look at these
commutation relations,
one thing they're telling us
is that we can't simultaneously
have eigenfunctions
of Lx and Ly.
However, the way that Lx and Ly
commute together is to form Lz.
That gives us some information.
That gives us some
magic, some power.
And in particular, much like
that moment in the harmonic
oscillator I said, well
look, we could write down
these operators as a.
Well look, we can write
down these operators,
which I'm going to call
L plus and L minus.
L plus is going to be
equal to Lx plus i Ly.
And L minus is going to
be equal to Lx minus I Ly.
Now Lx, Ly, those
are observables?
What can you say about
them as operators?
What kind of operators are
they since they're observables?
Hermitian, exactly.
So what's the Hermitian adjoint
of Hermitian plus i Hermitian?
Hermitian minus i Hermitian.
OK, good.
So L minus is the
adjoint of L plus.
So this is just going
to be a definition.
Let's take these to be the
definitions of these guys.
If we take their commutator,
something totally lovely
happens.
I'm not going to write
all the commutators.
I'm just going to
write a couple.
The first is if I take L squared
and I commute with L plus,
well, L plus is Lx
plus Ly, and we already
know that L squared
commutes with Lx
and it commutes with Ly.
So L squared
commutes with L plus.
And similarly for L minus,
it commutes with each term.
Question?
Oh, I'm sorry.
Lx.
Shoot, that was an x.
It just didn't look like it.
Lx minus i Ly.
So it commutes both
L plus and L minus.
But here's the
real beauty of it.
Lz with L plus is
equal to-- well,
let's just do
dimensional analysis.
L plus is Lx plus i Ly.
We know that Lz with Lx
is something like Ly.
And Lz with Ly is
something like Lx.
With factors of i's an h bars.
And when you work out the
commutator, which should only
take you second, you
get i h bar L plus.
And similarly, when we
construct Lz and L minus,
we get minus h bar L minus.
Are L plus an L minus Hermitian?
No, they're each
other's adjoints.
Lz is Hermitian.
And look at this
commutation relation.
What does that tell you?
From the first observation,
if we have an energy
or if we have an operator
e and an operator a
that commute in this
fashion, then this
tells you that the
eigenfunctions of this operator
are staggered in a the
ladder spaced by h bar.
The eigenvalues of Lz come
in a ladder spaced by h bar.
We can raise with
L plus, and we can
lower with L minus just like
in the harmonic oscillator
problem.
And we'll exploit the
rest of the-- we'll
deduce the rest of the structure
of the angular momentum
operator eigenfunctions next
time using this computation
relation.
See you next time.